our company is the leading mobility
service provider here in south korea and
our user base is more than 30 million
users which means most people in south
korea use our services our devil's
philosophy is to attack and recover the
failure as fast as we can since our
riley hailing service and navy services
are so critical to our users we put
relentless effort to achieve zero
downtime therefore our devil's team
mainly focuses on improving the
dictatability of system failures and
designing resultant systems that can
recover automatically so in this project
we wanted to re-architecture our systems
so that we can operate our micro
services uh both in our open cloud and
google cloud platform simultaneously the
first objective was to build an
environment that can respond to the
heavy verse traffic uh in case of the
southern traffic increases we were able
to
acquire additional resources in google
cloud platform very smoothly uh instead
of acquiring on-prem resources so i
think the future growth is order of kind
of two
or three times uh in terms of kind of
traffic and then the kind of service uh
we need to provide in terms of like a
year of your growth so that would be
huge in uh
if you think about the kind of the
amount of traffic we handle uh today
additional resources were required so we
rebalance the traffic so that a large
amount of on-prem traffic could be
processed in google cloud platform the
parts increased according to the hpa
settings in gke based on the number of
cores in gcp resources it increased
about four times compared to the usual
and it increased from the previously uh
quota 20
to about 80 percent our project teams
capability have grown together with
google teams engineering support
especially customer engineer and
technical account managers there is
bi-weekly regular meeting with our devos
team gcp team and gcp's partner gcp
customer success manager has taken care
of all the required gcp learning classes
we needed also it becomes a unique
differentiated point to
talk about
a long-term perspective roadmap and
further collaboration point between gcp
and us
under the strong support from the google
cloud team we were able to expedite a
work in progress to get into stable
first migration to gcp it was a very
pleasant experience to work together as
a team and expect more collaboration in
this year as well
project was very challenging for our
devos team since we only have used
on-prem cloud learning new technologies
as well as operating seamlessly between
two different infrastructure was very
difficult and migrating the new
architecture migrating to the new
architecture with zero service downtime
was very challenging as well however
thanks to the support from the google
cloud korea team we were able to migrate
the service smoothly and we were very
happy with the successful migration